democratic senator chris coons of
delaware joins us now he's a close
friend and advisor to president-elect
biden
senator good morning good morning great
to be on with you
yeah i want to start with the stimulus
bill as you know the house supported
this 275
to 130 ford had bipartisan support we
know that you're known for reaching
across the aisle
and have good relationships with your
republican colleagues
what are they thinking right now and is
this likely to pass
the senate frankly um for the last six
months democrats have tried to deliver
broader
stronger relief to the american people
as the pandemic has gotten worse
and worse and the votes that we're going
to see this week in congress
are just a repeat of that pattern the
the house democrats led by speaker
pelosi
quickly took up and passed an additional
bill
that would raise the stimulus payments
from 600 per person
to 2000 that was shot down by the senate
republican majority leader last night
i suspect we'll be fighting over this
for the rest of the week
we are now just three weeks from joe
biden's inauguration
as the next president of the united
states that will give us a chance to
reset and to show that we can work
together again
and deliver the relief the american
people need the results of the election
in georgia
where there are two senate seats at
stake next week may well determine
whether we can deliver more relief to
the american people next year
senator good morning it's david begneau
let me press you on that if i may
so if republican senators won't do it
with a republican president saying he
wants it
how's joe biden a democrat going to make
that happen when he comes into office i
mean i get that he'll try and work
across the aisle he's worked with
mcconnell in the past
but how is this actually going to happen
with him as president
david it's going to be very difficult
frankly president trump has been absent
for weeks
ever since losing the election he's
mostly been spending his time
golfing and tweeting and indulging
himself
in conspiracy theories about how he
actually won the election
president-elect joe biden is already
preparing
to put on the floor of the house and the
senate to move forward together with
congress
a package of urgently needed relief we
are in the very worst phase of this
public health crisis
this pandemic which has taken more than
three hundred thousand american lives
i am hoping and praying that republicans
once we get to the new year will
recognize
we have to deliver more relief to the
american people but i'm clear-eyed and
so is joe biden this will be very
difficult
and senator coons to that point about
the pandemic you have 20
million americans that were supposed to
get this first dose of the coveted
vaccine and we're not
uh even half at that point about 2
million and then just last week hope it
became the leading cause of death in
this country
what's happening behind the scenes and
are you satisfied with this rollout
absolutely not jericho look first to
celebrate the news that you just shared
the astrazeneca vaccine
has been approved in the united kingdom
we do have
vaccines that will be effective and safe
and we need a massive campaign to get
americans
access to this vaccine but frankly if
you look at joe biden's agenda for the
first hundred days that he's president
it includes making sure that we get the
basics done
that we've never done under president
trump's failed leadership
we don't have ppe for every single
frontline essential healthcare worker
we don't have tests for covet 19 that
are rapid
and effective available to every
american so a lot of the work we still
have to do
is to get personal protective equipment
and testing
and vaccines out to the american people
in the middle of a pandemic that's
gotten worse than ever
we have a lot of work ahead of us and a
key piece of that is strengthening the
ability
of our strained and tired public health
infrastructure
across the country to deliver vaccines
to the american people senator i've got
45 seconds left let me try this if i can
do you know who joe biden
will name attorney general
no i don't i am hoping that he will
choose my colleague
doug jones but there are a number of
very capable
and talented folks he is seriously
considering he has assembled an amazing
team for his cabinet
a team that is experienced that is ready
to work together on day one
and that reflects the diverse nature of
our country he's put together a great
cabinet
all right senator chris coons out of
delaware force thank you so much for
your time
thank you